OF JUSTICE I'M ALLOWED TO FIRE
PEOPLE IN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
>> Sean: GREGG, SARA,
CONGRESSMAN.
THE PRESIDENT IS MAKING MAJOR
HEADLINES TONIGHT DECLARING
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION
AND HE'D DO THAT SIT DOWN UNDER
AND WE'LL GET REACTION.
>> I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO IT
ACTUALLY.
THERE'S BEEN NO COLLUSION
WHATSOEVER.
THERE'S NO OBSTRUCTION
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO IT.
I'D LOVE TO DO IT.
AGAIN, I HAVE TO SAY, IT'S
SUBJECT TO MY LAWYERS AND ALL OF
THAT.
>> Sean: AND HE'S READY TO MEET
WITH THEM BUT HE'LL BE GUIDED BY
THE ADVICE OF HIS PERSONAL
VERY NICE PERSON AND GREAT
LAWYER.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> I'M FINE, THANKS.
THE ANSWER SO YOUR QUESTION IS
SIMPLE.
THE PRESIDENT ABSOLUTELY SHOULD
NOT SIT DOWN OR AGREE TO DO IT.
LOOK, YOU AND I BOTH KNOW THE
PRESIDENT.
HE SAID THERE IS NO COLLUSION,
IT.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE HIS LAWYERS
HAVE AGREED AND HE SAID IT'S
SUBJECT TO THE LAWYER.
NUMBER ONE, WHY SHOULD HE ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE FIRING OF
COMEY IF HE HAS A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO FIRE HIM.
TWO --
>> Sean: SHOULDN'T THAT BE HIS
ANSWER IF IN FACT HE GOES.
>> IT'S NEVER GOING END.
I KNOW FEDERAL PROSECUTORS.
>> Sean: I HAVE TO STOP YOU,
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
I BROUGHT THIS SCENARIO AND I
SAID WHAT IF I'M BEING
INTERVIEWED HE SAID YOU SAY NO
AND THEN YOU HAVE TO BE WILLING
TO SIT THERE.
IN MY LIFE I'M USED TO NO DEAD
AIR -- EVER.
I'D BE ABLE TO DO THAT BUT WE
KNOW PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HE'S
GOING TO SAY NO AND TELL YOU WHY
AND WHY AND WHY.
>> AND TALK ABOUT THIS AND THAT.
IT'S A TRAP.
THE SECOND REASON IS HE ONLY
NEEDS TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT
COMEY THEN WHAT CRIME ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT?
CRIME, ERGO, HE DOESN'T NEED TO
TO IMPLICATE HIM AND MAKE HIM
SEEM LIKE A LIAR.
IT'S RIDICULOUS TO GO IN FRONT
THAT'S SCARY IN TERM OF
UNREASONABLE SEARCH AND SEIZURE
AND NO WARRANTS AND IT NEVER
SHOULD HAVE HAPPENED.
THE PROBLEM HERE IS THEY DON'T
LIKE THIS PRESIDENT.
LOOK AT THIS TEAM THAT ROBERT
MUELLER PUT TOGETHER.
IS THAT FAIR?
STRZOK, WEISMAN, THEY'RE
BACKGROUNDS?
WEISMAN WITHHELD EXCULPATORY
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE KNOWS
IT BUT IT'S THE SAME DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE THAT'S ALLOWED
EVERYTHING YOU SAID THE LAST
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE?
YOU GO TO THE SUPREME COURT,
THIS IS MORE POLITICAL REASON
THAN A LEGAL REASON AND THAT'S
WHY THE PRESIDENT'S SAYING SURE
I'LL DO IT.
ALL THAT'S GONE ON.
I THINK HE'S OUT FOR BLOOD.
>> NOT ONLY OUT FOR BLOOD BUT
OUT TO SAVE HIS OWN BUTT --
>> Sean: BECAUSE OF ALL THE
REVELATIONS
>> Sean:
>> BECAUSE HE'S THE PERSON THAT
PAYCHECK WHY ARE MY DOLLARS
PAYING FOR THEM.
THEY NEED TO BE TAKEN OUT IN
CUFFS.
THIS IS NOT OUR JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
CONDESCENDING PEOPLE WHO THINK
THEY KNOW MORE THAN WE DO.
YOU'VE BEEN ON IT THE WHOLE